any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
today I'm pleased and thrilled to
welcome dr. Peter Diamandis who's the
CEO and founder of the of the XPrize
foundation is that right here is the
service executive chairman of the
foundation Chandrasekhar chairman a new
Shaun sorry who funded my first 10
million dollar crisis now our CEO yeah
wonderful
yes yeah no nye Anusha from her various
exploits including being one of the she
was she the first space tourist peter is
that right she was the first female
space to her staffers female-specific
yeah she was we had through space
adventures we sent eight people
privately and she was the first and only
woman female space tourists so far and I
wouldn't she I wouldn't say she's a
tourist because she did a lot of science
when she was up there she was definitely
working yeah very good you got to put
put everybody to work it's expensive to
send things up there although that price
may be coming down thanks to the efforts
that you're engaged in and some of the
aspects of the book that we'll be
talking about today so this is the
reason that we wanted to have you on
first of all I wanna just thank you for
the work that you do and behalf of the
arthur c clarke center for human
imagination at UCSD this is the into the
impossible podcast which you recognize
as one of arthur c clarke s-- three laws
the first one being that any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic and you
engaged in a lot of magical activities
we'll talk about those the second law is
the only way to find out what is
possible is to go a little bit beyond
into the impossible and so we started
this podcast four years ago now I think
it is we've had visionaries thought
leaders politicians Nobel Prize winners
they're all all different gamuts and
thanks to you for your long-standing
help for that with the center thank you
thank you I had the pleasure of knowing
to Clark and working with him and
visiting him in Sri Lanka a few times
and some fun stories there we can get
into if you like yeah that will be a
real treat and aren't too many friends
of Arthur that I've had on the show
so today the occasion that brings you
here of course I love and take advantage
of every opportunity I can to chat with
you and pick your brain about things but
it's the publication with your Co off
there Steven Kotler of the third this
doesn't show up not great unless I hold
it over here but the future is faster
than you think so this is your third in
a series of three books I believe this
is the last final installment of the
series that began with bold way back it
began with abundant abundance re you
know 2012 right that was an almost eight
years ago nine years ago will be there
will be a fourth because we're gonna re
release abundance on the 10th
anniversary the the thesis behind
abundance that the world is getting
better than anyone knows and despite you
know the Copa 19 pandemic that we're in
by almost every measure and we can talk
about that obviously the world has
gotten better on so many different
levels in terms of access to information
and computational power uplifting of
people throughout society the reduced
cost of energy of water of food of
healthcare of Education all of these
things and the thesis around abundance
that we are going from a community a
world of scarcity to a little abundance
is more valid now than ever before and
the data is extraordinary and so we're
gonna do a ten year anniversary not just
an update it'll be sort of a the same
chunks of what we covering humanity's
basic needs for Maslow's hierarchy but
we're gonna return to how we're creating
energy abundance water abundance food
abundance healthcare abundance and so
forth then and that will be a 2020 to
fourth book if you would yeah I'm going
to talk about this and how it reminds me
of
Nicholas Nasim celebs series which I
think he calls the insert or you know
kind of the Black Swan and anti fragile
and a third book which his name I'm
blanking on but but kind of this is your
triplet my tryptych vision into the
future but being well predicated on past
accomplishments and looking forward to
the future and since you brought it up I
was going to get to it but yeah we're
kind of come up on the 10th anniversary
in 2022 and but what I started thinking
about is what if this book came out in
this current book the futures faster
than you think Bretton was Steven Kotler
if that was written and published in
2021 what would it have been different I
mean obviously I think recognition of
the pandemic but I would have recognized
the pandemic as a forcing factor for the
acceleration one of the things that's
extraordinarily true is everything we
talk about in the book and the book
really focuses on the next decade and
how every industry food water energy
healthcare education you know insurance
finance how every one of those
industries will be changing over the
next decade and the pandemic is just
accelerating that it's accelerating it
by a lot so I would have basically
looked at that as a forcing function so
we're seeing a real acceleration in
transforming the educational world to
digital education we're gonna see a
massive push towards digital health care
health care at home health care with
your AI we're going to see robots coming
into the workforce because companies
can't afford do you have a human
workforce that is fragile as we've seen
and so we're seeing the insertion of
robots coming in so a lot of what we
talk with eponymous cars flying cars all
of that stuff is moving faster and
faster and so I think we're gonna see in
2020 two or three years of accelerated
digitization and dematerialization D
monetization and democratization yeah
when I look at the book and I see these
overarching theme
and the impact of what you call the six
DS that we'll get into undoubtedly you
know all stemming from the first D the D
Mondas D but I think Steven Kotler
should you know at least add a middle my
initial D to for parody sake but but
from the perspective that that the world
is you know moving more and more towards
the scalable towards this dream of
reproducible error-correcting resilient
systems I've heard it said you know I
can't wait to get back to normal and I
want to get your thoughts is this the
new normal
are we going to see how so yeah go ahead
yeah so I I mean when people say I can't
wait to get back to work I see you are
at work this is work this is what it's
like we are you know it takes 30 to 90
days for humans to create new habits of
repeated consistency right for neural
programming so to speak and our being in
this you know sheltered in place
whatever you want to call it is creating
you habit so I think a lot of companies
are not going to rent office space we're
going to see a real hit on commercial
office we're going to have a lot more
people working remotely and virtualized
organizations we're going to see a lot
more you know home schooling I have two
boys that are about to turn nine in June
and they've gone from a high-priced
private school to being homeschooling
and you know I'm sort of enjoying the
hours I get to spend teaching him at
home so am I going to spend a college
level tuition at a school you know a lot
of change is coming there are elements
that will go back but there is
definitely gonna be a new normal and and
I think even if you could go back the
way it was there are certain things that
weren't wrong I'm in the best health had
been I'm getting the most sleep I've
done look
I asked heavy freshed I'm happy damn it
has been good for you yeah well you know
I want to be sensitive to all the people
and I've had people I know have died
real people that I know have have been
on ventilators and so forth and I'm you
know I'm still there is but every year
there are people who pass away from from
influenza from car crashes from all
kinds of things and so you know whenever
we have anything new we react people
don't like change
people like waking up in the morning and
believing the world is the same as it
was at the night before so if all of a
sudden we had been all on horse and
buggy and then the car came along and we
started seeing you know 1.3 million
deaths per year from the car that were
there the year before we would it would
be global out cries against the car and
how are we killing a million people a
year but we've gotten numb to those
numbers now that's not to say the
coronavirus and one of my companies is
in the blood antibody testing and in the
vaccine development another one is in
the therapeutic side so I'm privy to
what's going on and this virus is
different than normal and I remember
when I was in medical school I was at
Mass General Hospital when the first
AIDS cases were coming and maich IV
infections and it was like what is going
on here we have no idea what it was and
and it was a great deal of fear and we
now see it as a a manageable disease or
infection yeah in fact we're using my
part of therapies that used for sickle
cell anemia that used the AIDS virus if
I'm not mistaken as a drug delivery
network and we'll talk about that
obviously you're an expert on that
you're no longer you're not a practicing
physician but you were trained as a
medical doctor yeah I don't
I would advise anybody to come to me for
any conditions well me neither he'll
though you know sometimes they ask me
medical advice but one of the things
that's been in the zeitgeist lately has
been this notion of exponential 'ti and
exponential effects and in your first
book in abundance you start talking
about these exponential functions and in
bold you continue that theme in the
second book and really it's been amazing
to me that people that are completely
you know non-technical self-declared
Luddites you know they're talking about
logarithmic plots and graphs and do you
think this is now entered into you know
the zeitgeist as they say in a way that
you couldn't have really forecasts a few
years back even yeah I was joking on one
of my tweets saying it took a global
deadly virus to teach people about
exponential growth and and it's true
people have gotten that we're in the
exponential phase but you know every
exponential falls off and we have what's
called an s-curve in the early days been
exponential we have a deceptive growth
period where it looks linear and then we
hit this hyper growth of Exponential's
which you know in the u.s. at the time
we're doing this podcast a lot of cities
from New York and others are in that
phase and then eventually it it falls
off either it consumes its raw material
in this case human hosts or it hits some
physical limitations whether it's the
you know the frequency of laser light
for creating a microchip
so yeah it's we've learned though we've
learned a lot about Exponential's and
yeah so just keeping in the medical
theme I want to draw listeners attention
to events that we've done in the past
along with our mutual friend Julian
Guthrie when space technologies book
really written about you and and and
other pioneers of the early you know
commercial space age and we'll get into
that hopefully but I want to take an
even bigger step back and we found in
the arthur c clarke center we were also
deeply affiliated with the the XPrize
that was dick dedicated and named
or what I assume is probably your
favorite show in history the tricorder
from Star Trek yeah can you give us an
update on the tricorder X PRIZE of
course dr. Eric theory MD ph.d is the
director of the Clark center here but I
thought I wouldn't be interested to get
your impression of that and then segue
into how technologies like that could be
useful as Diagnostics for the next phase
I don't want to say when this goes away
because I don't think it will go away I
think we're gonna have to adapt to it as
a fact of life this virus and how it's
going to come back and the different
permutations that it will undergo but
can you say something about the XPrize
for the tricorder X Prize so so yeah I
mean the two things that got me going in
life and got me excited about about
science I'm excited about space were was
the Apollo program and Star Trek I used
to joke that the Apollo program showed
us what humanity could do right now and
that scientific documentary called Star
Trek showed us where the world was going
and and that was for me always the my
vision of today and tomorrow and then
when when I did see the government
program fulfilling that potential then I
started getting sad
then angry and then okay how the heck do
I do this myself and that was for with
them the mental evolution that led to a
whole series of companies from
international space university which is
where I met Eric Berry is one of my
students there and that arthur c clarke
through ISU and others in star trek is
an incredible universe
some call it a TV show it's a universe
of an appositive abundance minded sunny
we can solve any problem there is
infinite diversity and and it's really a
universe of tolerance across species and
ways of thinking and and the golden rule
to a large degree and if you look at
Star Trek
it's incredible what what what gene
roddenberry did I mean the you know the
ideas that he put forward the tricorder
being one of them the idea of of warp
drive right I mean the the thought of
going from one location to another
location by warping space I mean you
know how else we gonna get light-years
away and so it just there was a lot of
hard science-based ideas that were there
so I've been in the medical world in
some way shape or form all my life I had
two companies go on my last year of
medical school like I said I barely
graduated I think I graduated with the
least credits ever issued by by Harvard
for a medical degree and I mean my deal
I made with my Dean was listen if you
let me graduate I'll promise not to
practice and he kept his end and I kept
mine but so the idea was could we
develop the tricorder in the tricorder
was the ability of a device to to
diagnose an individual's medical goal
and what we have today isn't healthcare
we have sick here we have a world in
which you're taking care of after you're
sick and then barely taken care of but
what if you had the capability to
monitor your state of health with high
precision consistently day in and day
out so I'm a pilot
I fly a couple different airplanes is as
Brian I think you're a pilot as well is
that correct yeah or a pilot and we are
also parents of twins yes and common
yeah so before you take off or I take
off I make sure all of my systems are in
normal operating zone everything is good
and otherwise that wouldn't I wouldn't
take off and because our airplanes are
are got hundreds of sensors and hundreds
of microprocessor is monitoring
everything all the time
but for our bodies we know so little
about what's truly going on in
our bodies and we go for a health
check-up once in a while and you know we
what we get is some cursory overview and
it's only when you end up in a hospital
with some pain in the side that you say
oh and you go and the physician digs in
but it's possible to actually monitor
your physiology in great detail and the
tricorder was part of that I wouldn't go
into the details but it had to be detect
some dozen to 15 different parameters
that would give you an indication of
disease but eventually the goal here is
to make us the CEOs of our own health
where there is an AI our own version of
Jarvis from Ironman that's monitoring
your blood glucose your your your blood
chemistry is your metabolism in a way
that if anything goes out of whack does
let's go check and see why this is
anything other than perfect yeah not
that kind of segues nicely into one of
the topics that you bring up in the
future is faster than you think and
that's the advent of wearables due to
the you know decentralization and they
and basically the the shrinking effect
that technology is having that such that
we can all have on our fingers and in
our pockets we already have a
supercomputer so why not link that with
5g networks to a cloud to do Diagnostics
based on you know I wear this this is
then or a ring and this is nothing but I
have an aura ring
I have mine right here we go good I was
gonna say this is my ordering I have the
next generation when it's in this just
to make you jealous there's so few ways
I can do that but the but the or ring
you know tracks these these parameters
while you sleep and it kind of tells you
how many times your twins well in my
case my twins are much younger than
yours woke me up or disturbed me and my
temperature and so forth but I want to
just bring to your attention I don't
know if you ever heard this quote before
but it's a quote from the Talmud which
is one of the sacred books in the Jewish
faith that I practice but the the code
always tickles me because it's it goes
like that's because the best doctors go
to hell meaning that there's sort of
this this this prowess that the doctors
have and maybe rightfully so to deal
with the OP the tremendous stress and
challenges that they deal with I have
many physician friends that that when
they cure things when they do things
it's part of their it's almost part of
their makeup the same way that I feel
like I once heard John and Martha King
who you know from the king's schools
from flying they said once you get your
pilot's license it changes your identity
what will happen you know when medicine
becomes so distributed to use a D a D
word and becomes really outsourced to
these Jarvis's these clouds and so forth
what will that do to the medical
profession to the ego to the personality
the identity of physicians that are
actually practicing them in them and the
future yeah
so it's interesting I think for the next
decade it's really gonna be about AI H I
collaboration human intelligence and
artificial intelligence working
collaboratively I think that someplace
in the next three to seven years I
probably peg it at your four or five
it's going to become malpractice to make
a diagnosis without the use of AI right
so you can imagine you go to a doctor
who looks at you reviews your x-ray or
reviews any other
blood workup you have and then says
you're fine or you have this that
physician god bless them all I come from
a family of doctors mm-hmm
there's no way that that doctor is able
to understand all of the data available
to him or her right 3.2 billion letters
from your genome sequence iam microbiome
Irma tableau all the imagery and so
forth or be able to recognize the
thousands of journal articles that have
come out in the last 24 hours around the
world but and/or look at all of the the
data exhaust that you have left right
we're leaving data everywhere how often
we have coughed what the sound of that
cough was right can be picked up by
Alexa or your Siri I mean there's
massive amount of data that is is you
know where you've traveled to and who
happened to be infected with this with
the SARS co2 that you were near next to
you so AI is going to be a critical part
of this and I think it's going to allow
doctors and nurses health care workers
to be more human versus trying to crunch
through all of the data and not make a
mistake yeah I went to a talk by I'm
sure you know Eric Topol is we're here
at Scripps Research Institute and
vacation of his book which hopefully I'm
hoping to get him on the show at some
point deep medicine where yeah he shows
a car funny he's great when he gives his
talk Susie always has these funny
cartoons from around the web and one of
them is you know a doctor staring you
know at a computer screen typing away
and this is the view this is how doctors
are seen by patients and you know to
them they see themselves as you know as
these kind of Jonas Salk characters and
doing all this great and they do and
it's it's one of the hardest jobs that
one can imagine but looking or looking
at it I think you're absolutely right
you have these devices these listener
mold devices not just the wearables
connected to it you could have
instantaneous studies and all serviced
up to 5g networks you talked about in
the book and maybe we can talk a
aside track down that route as you know
we're here in San Diego Qualcomm is a
huge player in San Diego and they're a
big force behind 5g Y for the average
layperson out there that's not as dialed
into the matrix as we are why is it so
important why isn't it just I mean my
life didn't change much when I went from
bridgitte LTE it's a little bit faster
but why is it gonna be such a quantum
breakthrough they talk about in the book
well so 5g is coming at the perfect time
for a number of things and the
parameters of 5g that make it valuable
isn't just speed and tell us the latency
so a 4G network is able to deliver you
in the tens to low hundreds of megabits
connection speed or vibe G squarely gets
you into the hundreds of megabits and
into the gigabits level but then the
latency is such that the delay between
you taking an action and that actually
being registered by the computer network
or by the end-effector is minimal and
what that still allow for is virtual
reality and augmented reality and remote
surgery and the ability to really take
the computation out of the device and
put it into the cloud so right now my
phone is doing a lot of calculations
onboard but in the processors in the
phone but as you well know when I need
to do something complicated the data is
sent to the cloud where it is analyzed
and then the ants are sent back we're
eventually going to do that with our
brains to where we offload computation
from our neocortex to the cloud and the
answers come back as well like you know
I'll be able to understand some of the
math and physics say you're able to
crunch that I have no idea how to do but
you know if I've got my my processor I
have a thousand Amazon
yeah you know notes supporting me I'll
be able to help me yeah yeah it's it's
not it's not brain surgery it's it's
just rocket and ice but I want to talk
about rocket science next in all
seriousness so you admitted to these
twin muses that got you so they pumped
up in that in your youth you know one
being Star Trek and the kind of
socio-cultural implications of going
into space and the other was the Apollo
program I just interviewed professor
David Kaiser from your alma mater MIT
and David's as a physicist and also a
historian of science and he's written a
wonderful book called quantum legacies
and he talks about kind of how the 20th
century was this physicist century and a
lot of it centered upon the war effort
of World War two and how after World War
two a bunch of technologies one started
you know and fairly heavily associated
almost exclusively with MIT that being
the radar project they're MIT rad lab
and the other one being the famous the
famous Manhattan Project how those
technologies really crystallized physics
as kind of the prestige cornerstone
subject of the 20th century so much so
that following the war you have
physicists assigned you know Secret
Service escorts to go to conferences you
know that hasn't happened to me yet
recently now I'm wondering you know with
that being the notion of course then of
course the German rocketry program
Wernher von Braun so you discuss in your
books you know brought to America then
launched you know what became the Apollo
program and the space race that we ended
up winning and I'm wondering wouldn't
you have a situation now as we don't
have you know we don't have a foe per se
we have what we're in a war we're in a
battle and every life is infinitely
precious I believe but we're in this
battle we're not fighting an enemy can't
Cove it in your mind kind of nucleate
this progress in biotechnology beyond
the wearables beyond the
commercialization but but can it
nucleate a century of biology so the
reality is I think that we are fighting
a war and
for the first time in ever the human
race is a singular enemy we've never had
there's never been a time like this
before
I mean the entire human race every
planet every scientist and what is
incredible when I think about it rough
back-of-the-envelope calculation there's
somewhere between a hundred million and
two hundred million doctors nurses
scientists engineers technologists all
taken an aim at the Koba 19 pandemic and
that's extraordinary again and the level
of collaboration put aside all the
political stuff the amount of scientific
collaboration going on between
scientists in every every country and
position around the world is amazing and
I think that this pandemic is going to I
think you use the term nuclea lot of new
sexy professions like epidemiologists
biologists as well as as physician
biologists and scientists you know it's
interesting were we have new weapons to
bring to bear in this war
CRISPR in gene therapy for the first
time ever yeah that's that that's
certainly you know much to look forward
to I come like physicist friends you
know we had a whole century you know
it's time to let our biology about the
biological colleagues you know share in
the spotless it as long as we both long
as the physicists and biologists even
the chemists are able to outstrip the
the the nba's well I want to get into
another chapter in the book it's
actually my favorite chapter in the book
when you talk about education and I want
to talk about the confluence of
technologies and of new modalities of
thinking it's not just a technology that
enables us to develop these things in
the way that we think of life once you
know I don't know if you've ever had
this experience but I had my you know
one of my two-year-olds tried to swipe
right and my FET not that she's on
tinder or anything but trying to swipe
my face like it was an iPad
and you know and that just made me
realize no child born before you know
2011 when the iPad came out ever would
have done that and so now as a species
we're really interacting and connecting
different ways because of Technology and
how it enables education an educator
such as myself and I consider you an
educator because you're you have a
university as well as now it's you know
sort of a for-profit you know where it's
different than the traditional degree
granting universities but I wonder how
much longer will that be true well I
eventually will eventually be sort of
outsourced to you know another version
of you know singularity University or
will I be outsourced to you know I
learned from me when you can talk to
Galileo himself an avatar form
yeah so I do believe we are going to
reinvent how we educate people
significantly and and the example I used
normally is I speak about the notion
that if my son wants to learn about
ancient Greece rather than picking up a
book that is probably boring and written
by some historian who has mediocre
writing skills and so forth or trying to
read the you know the original works and
you know in ancient Greek or some
translation that'd be really tough but
imagine instead putting on your VR
goggles now VR today is at a relatively
low resolution but it's rapidly
improving and we have lots of drivers
and we're seeing lots of companies going
into this obviously HTC and and Facebook
with oculus and Apple and others and
Qualcomm again part of the San Diego
Arthur Clark ecosystem is creating ships
driving a lot of this revolution but we
are moving towards a time when I'll be
able to put on my VR goggles and I'll be
in ancient Greece and it'll be
photorealistic
I see some dude with a toga on a piece
of marble over there and the floating
overs head
it says Plato and I walk over to say hey
what up Plato and he goes hello what's
your name
and we have a conversation and I say
tell me about your day what did you eat
what are you writing what are you
thinking about and and I have an
experience that is unlike anything I'd
ever have in a book or even speaking to
the best of professors so and that Plato
is he is an avatar driven by in a neural
net an AI that is everything ever
written by him or about him you know
instantiated in that in that in that
avatar and that's going to be true for
any historical figure or fictitious
figure and so it's immersive education
so when will we get there I mean Ray
Kurzweil my co-founder of singularity
University and our Chancellor believes
that will have human-level AI by 2029
I see no you know he's been holding
steadfast on that so I'll believe him on
that so
that's yes we're gonna reinvent
education the best AR the best educators
in the world will P will be a is in
interim it'll be again we're in this
next decade is a decade of human machine
collaboration but at some point it will
be just you know and just the same way
that Google has demonetized and
democratized
accessed information an AI will do
monetize and democratize access to the
best education and the best healthcare
and will effectively be available to
everyone equally for free yeah and
that's sort of what I when I brought up
with David I said you know I read an
article that said something to the
effect that mi t--'s president our
president the board said something to
the effect that we could actually accept
you know twice as many five times as
many students as we do with no
degradation and student quality and
performance and that seems to me to say
that you know look at all these people
from not just America but around the
world being denied access to an MIT
education or UCSD education etc and the
question is - because I think it's true
here too that you know what relevance
will there be for a place like this when
you can scale up a partnership between
San Diego and Qualcomm to deliver you
know this is an incredibly immersive
experience and when I talk with my
friend David Kaiser he said no they
still need a you know a sage on the
stage is scraping away a one piece of
rock and another piece of rock and you
know I'm too much of a gentleman as you
know to really stridently this is great
with him but but I I'm worried about the
future of my profession that I don't
know how it will compete this is a model
that goes back to you know the first
century of the of the last millennium
you know with the University of Bologna
and Alexandria they basically thousand
year old institutions how many of those
survived and he thinks that's a sign of
their resiliency I wonder about your I
mean it seems to me you're saying your
alma mater you know might might its days
might be numbered in its current form if
so what will replace it well be the
circle you know online-only
yeah so we have to think differently
about education first of all education
is not one thing there is education is
human human interaction I became an
adult in college right living on my own
dealing with problems not being under
the the roof of my parents
so there's a whole growing up at a
distance to human the human a human side
of that experience there is learning
skills and those skills come in two
different two different forms I mean
there's stuff that if you're a physician
you can do a lot of VR you can do a lot
in in AR but being there the old saying
watch one do one teach one is probably
get a hold true until we have brain
Peter interface and you can do a full-on
simulation that you can't distinguish
from reality and then there's to be
learning facts and figures and equations
and and bodies of work but a lot of that
is going to be done better in in in AI
VR environment where I'm learning
quantum physics I can visualize it in a
way and see experiments done and feel
quantum physics versus just seeing some
guy or gal with chalk dust in a
blackboard on there so there were in
differentiate different parts but the
other here's the most interesting thing
going back to the universities and
you're right the first University
started you know a lot of them came out
of the religious world a thousand ad and
then the last 500 years we've seen the
growth of the large universities and
even a hundred years ago you would go to
get your grad your university degree
from age 18 to age 22 and by the time
you were done first of all two things
happen one the world was not moving very
fast things were not changing
dramatically and then you were dead by
40 so your education that had to last
you 18 years well things didn't change
today the world is changing at lightning
speeds and so I think what is really
gonna happen prior is that we're gonna
go to university subscription models
where it's a lifelong membership so I
when I joined I'm accepted to MIT or
UCSD or wherever I be yeah I am I'm
subscribed to and constantly learning
and that learning is going to come in
very different methodologies where if
I'm wearing augmented reality glasses
and this month I'm focused on history as
of walking down the street my MIT
algorithm is teach me about the history
of wherever it happened to be and I'm
thinking in that way I'm
constantly upgrading my knowledge base
of experience base now when you when you
look forward it sounds you know that
these things could be negative for
college presidents but these these often
offer opportunities for talk about yet
when you digitize something UD
materialize it UD monetizing me
democratize it so here's the example you
know instead of paying a hundred
thousand or twenty thousand dollars for
a four-year degree what if I'm paying
you know five thousand dollars a year
but I have a an MIT membership that's
gonna last a fifty years and I can offer
it not just four thousand to grads and
four thousand grads but I can offer it
to you know a million people so yeah I
think that we're in agreement there I
think that this especially due to the
co-ed experience um you know I've had my
colleagues be you know extremely
frustrated night preparing lectures
given a week to do so you know that take
universities that are only online
lecturer and an online university might
take two years to construct a real
brand-new ab initio course and you know
and these other universities like you're
saying with your top of your twins you
know you're you're finding out well how
much are they actually getting education
how much of it is babysitting how much
of it is is you know a socialization
which is very important I think and and
other types of activities I want to move
from from that to talk about some things
because I always think of you as this
irrepressible optimist I think that your
data driven you're driven by facts
you're rational thinker but you're
intrinsically optimistic and I always
there yeah yeah and I always like to
kind of take the contrary side if you're
a pessimist that I'd ask you what you're
optimistic about but I want to talk
about these kind of in the dark side of
some of these Fox 60s as you described
in the book including you know this this
potential for for for the lowering of
cost and the D monetization and
the lowering of the potential barrier as
we say physicists say to entry for many
of these things a lot of times in the
past that's been a good things the high
barrier has prevented rogue nations from
getting nuclear bioweapons what happens
when you know you can get Edmund
Scientifics CRISPR kit and some some
rogue state can then take over not even
a rogue state it could be a rogue
individual and or deploying drones you
talk very favorably about you know the
sky darkening with these over taxis and
and so forth what about the dark side of
these being used and then by malicious
actors so but that's always been the
case I mean we have how many millions of
cars which are you know 2 ton devices
traveling at 100 kilometers an hour it's
a lot of energy and they could be used
any time shape way or form to you know
to kill you know 30 people in crowded
areas I mean this is not the new
technology that offers this these
dangers they've been around what new
technologies offer is the potential to
monitor these problems and to solve them
right so one of the things that make
gives me hope is we're heading towards a
world of what I call radical
transparency and so in 2020 we have
something like 20 billion connected
devices and a trillion sensors and by
2030 a hundred trillion sensors and a
hundred billion connected devices and
what that means is we're gonna enter a
world in which you can know anything you
want anytime you want anywhere you want
and it's becomes harder and harder to do
anything a secret so you know when when
there's a drone flying over a herd of
rhinoceros or elephants the poachers
stay away it's you know most people do
things you know in the cloud of secrecy
but lip secrecy becomes more more
difficult then you think twice about
you're gonna do and I teach my kids
gotta be careful you know whatever you
do there's a camera watching there is
digital trails so you know the question
is and I asked people all the time do
you really think we are living in a
world of privacy I mean so Brian what do
you think do you think there's privacy
out there no in fact I had this
conversation with Dave Rubens a
well-known podcaster YouTube you know
he's complaining about getting D
monetized or he platformed and you know
I asked him the kind of he's also an
optimist and I said you know he claims
to be and I said well you sound kind of
pessimistic and I wonder how people are
how many people are gonna feel bad for
you if you go from a million YouTube
subscribers to 999 thousand and I said
you know you're really inverting the
hierarchy and this is the point of
agreement that he and I had where as it
used to be you know in the 50s and 60s
it was the kind of far-right or the
government really that was suppressing
or invading privacy in McCarthy etc etc
now it's been kind of open source so
you're absolutely right I think you have
to come and if you come of age in this
digital era you have this this
recognition of the benefits and the
faults of these of these massively
prevalent devices I'm I'm a technologist
and love technology I'm a geek of a nerd
like you I love it I think I breathe it
I breathe it I want to see you know they
once asked you know Richard Fineman is
another MIT grad like yourself and they
said you know like how long do you want
to live and he was like I live forever
and you know that's something we can
talk about in the medicine and the
future of living chapter but he said and
the interviewer said it's not depressing
like all your friends will die and he
was like now think of all the great
theorems I'm gonna get to see in the
future like proved and new particles
discovered and all these amazing things
and he died you know relatively young in
the 1989 but I wonder you know there is
you know kind of this I call it certain
list this the malaise of of progress we
have this ubiquity of things just I'll
give you an example GPS like many people
can't get around you know even their own
hometown without GPS and I wonder if
it's as it has with my children you know
trying to swipe my face because the
prevalence of iPad technology if
the GPS has made us collectively as a
species you know it used to be if you
didn't remember where that you know
casaba melon tree was you were dead you
know like that's your brain implanted
dopamine so that you could remember
where it was and never forget it and so
I wonder you know are there side again
this is on the only pessimistic pardons
challenge you on this just are there
ways that technology is increasing this
ability both for people to have you know
everybody to have equal say and the
democracy side of things not just that
equal say but to do so with zero cost
like it used to be if I want to tell you
Peter you know I don't think you're
gonna make it as a center for the
Celtics you know I think you know you're
not you're not big enough to do that
Peter like I could only do that in
person and you can punch me you know
where it counts but now I could do it
online now Peter you can't make this a
no so so what is that is there a
downside to that just the
democratization of everything should
some things be kept behind gates just
being devil's advocate so here's the
deal we don't have a choice I mean it's
like there's no velocity button there's
no velocity dial or on/off switch
stopping technology and so forth so this
is a evolutionary force we are the
carrier wave for technological evolution
all the way to stop it is to like end
everything and we can set it back Wars
and different things and depressions set
it back doesn't stop it and and the
question is what are you trying to
maximize for you know I would argue that
if what we are measuring at the end of
this continuous progress is the
uplifting of humanity meaning the
ability for every man woman and child to
have access to all the food water energy
healthcare education entertainment that
they want that that this march of
technology is is amazing but yet we
romanticize the past
and yeah there's gonna be trades I mean
I mean just face it
I can't milk a cow I can't go and plant
enough diverse food products to make a
meal that I would be proud of but that's
fine because I spend my time doing other
things you know there's a Indian yogi by
the name of a side guru know if you know
his name I had a chance to meet him a
brilliant man and he said we are finally
able to take a vacation from survival
and that just really stuck with me right
if you look at all of human existence
human species Homo sapiens are about
five million years old give or take
by whatever definition you want to make
a cutoff for for for the human coming on
time scene and for 99.999% of that it
has been fundamental survival pretty
brutal brutal survival hmm and it's just
now the last you know 20 30 40 years
that we can sort take a break from them
saying you know that's that find some
good entertainment or I'm gonna choose
this wine over this wine or this you
know fruit from Whole Foods within a
thousand different options to have
that's insane
that's amazing yeah yeah soon you'll be
able to 3d print that as you Britt as
you bring up in the book so and another
trend that you brought that you brought
up just to push a little gently on the
button you know you talked a lot about
the value of cities in the book and and
and you know the efficiency of the city
and I think you know one thing that
kovat at least is brought out to me as
this realization that I'm pretty happy
not living in a megalopolis and and
although I have to say in all fairness
you talk about the ability of a flying
car you know being able to take you from
a suburb or nexor or even the rural
areas of the world into the city should
we need to go in there or you just work
remotely from home or you know on the
while you're you know kind of being a
you know just learning about how to milk
a cow I don't know I mean these this
time has been good one of my hobbies has
become you know growing seeds and just
as we started out the podcast talking
about your checklist your pre-flight
checklist yeah I started growing like
the heirloom tomatoes like in these tiny
little Burpee seed boxes and I became
like I'm ashamed to admit but like there
was a day when like the sprout started
coming up and I could see there a little
flower is gonna be like an heirloom
tomato you know took five weeks to get
this damn seed you know soon you'll be
able to print it out I suppose but but
for now seed shortly and that one of my
kids my things my seven year old he came
by and he like knocked it over and I'm
ashamed say you know I can't why like
how could you be so careless it took me
so much time to grow this little 3 inch
long haul thing you know putting putting
it in the Sun taking it out of the Sun
because it was cold in San Diego last
night or whatever and I realized how
much attachment you have to things when
you make them yourself and so I think
there'll be a positive side when you're
actually make 3d printing you you know
different things or when you're actually
involved the education of the children
instead of outsourcing not to the state
you know in all cases so I think there
is a tremendous amount of optimism that
that your book brings up but it's
realistic I think that there is there's
so much you know that's why I want to
live forever because I want to see what
the future brings and you know we can
maybe we'll talk another time to know
your time is a little bit short but I do
want to hit a couple of things first is
your recollections of arthur c clarke
you mentioned that you met him at at
least one occasion can you tell us a
little bit about so let you remember him
I met him in 1982 and I was a college
student I was at MIT that time and I
went to the United Nations conference on
the peaceful uses of outer space and he
was giving a talk and I was there with
two other colleagues Bob Richards and
Todd Holley Todd since passed away and
we were there representing students but
exploration development of space sense
and wisdom we were there as the guest of
David C Webb one of our advisors and we
ended up befriending
Arthur and long story on how that
happened but we're having dinner with
him and we over dinner were talking
about SEDs and our goals and our
missions and all of that and he was
telling us about the stories of
post-world War two his working with
German and Russian scientists and what
the world was like and ended up giving
him the moniker uncle Arthur and and he
agreed to become an advisor to says and
he then went from becoming an advisor to
said to becoming the Chancellor of the
international space University and I
would meet him every time he would come
to New York to focus on his next books
that were there with 2010 was being
filmed and then I went twice to Sri
Lanka to meet him in Colombo and he was
just an amazing supporter of our work
and it was he had such a deep British
voice to go hello Peter
yeah I can't do it but it was it was
just amazing amazing to get to know him
yeah so yeah it was great no that's
wonderful so I'm gonna finish up the
conversation with some questions that I
call the final five and that's really
kind of your outlook and some advice
that you can give perhaps but the first
thing I want to talk you know you talked
a lot about you know DNA and and kind of
this this magical invention that allows
us to have this diversity and and
facility of life as we know it and I
think you know with your many books now
this is the third in this series
hopefully they'll be the next edition
will come out in 2022 on the 10th
anniversary of abundance I want to ask
you some questions about books because I
love books you were kind enough and
gracious enough to endorse losing the
Nobel Prize my book deeply appreciative
for that but I want to talk about what
books mean to you and you know perhaps
the future of these books actually we
have a copy that we'll give away to a
listener this copy here we're also going
also had the Kindle and the audiobook
version that I bought myself and those
wonderful formats are wonderful but
about the physical book what do you what
do you feel is the and I apologize I've
got the governor of Utah we found on a
conference table so I do a lot of
reading inaudible I love physical books
I love the fact that we've got I have a
whole library of books but I do a lot of
my consumption on audible these days
which is why I read my book myself it
was extraordinary yeah it was a fun
experience but I love books books for me
are a moment of a conversation with the
author and most of my greatest
inventions and business ideas have come
out of my my reading books and taking
notes and thinking about it and so forth
but anyway so that's my experiences look
let's take one more of the final five
and last one is I'll just say that the
the title of this podcast course is into
the impossible and I want to know what
sing at age 20 or 30 perhaps seemed
impossible to you but now seems
perfectly feasible because you took that
venture into the impossible man god I
mean just the ability to start companies
as quickly as possible and find amazing
people and go after moonshots right to
the limit when I'm driven by my
massively transformative purpose I talk
about that in bold extraordinarily and
had to go from an MTP the moonshot just
the ability that you know I don't have
to read about someone else or hope
someone else is gonna go and do this
thing build this thing and so forth I
can do that we are so empowered as
entrepreneurs to go and make stuff
happen
it is absolutely extraordinary now I
want to thank you and your colleague
Steven Kotler for making this happen the
future is faster than you think how
converging technologies are transforming
business industries in our lives Peter
thank you so much as always here the
best and I wish you Brian success and
health bye bye thank you for your thanks
for you
and for your spread the word of one of
the things that you do
be well my friend five here take a bye
now
[Music]
[Music]
while any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
magic